if you are drinking coffee this morning
we're mainlining it like we are you may
not be thinking about what it took to
get those beans from crop to cup but the
man you're about to hear from sure did
moukhtar Alton chao-li lived through a
harrowing journey and a dramatic escape
to bring one of the oldest coffees from
Yemen to the rest of the world his story
is now being told in a new book by
celebrated author author Dave Eggers CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor sat down
with them at the Hudson Hotel librarian
lounge right here in New York
Mokhtar Alcon shali was 24 and working
as a doorman at a San Francisco
high-rise when he got a delirious idea
leave the Bay Area for Yemen and start a
coffee business what he didn't plan on
was getting trapped in the middle of a
civil war it was a story Dave Eggers
felt compelled to tell I'm always
attracted to stories of self invention
and entrepreneurship and you know self
creation and that's what that's what
he's done
nobody dreams the American Dream better
than immigrants and the sons and
daughters of immigrants Alcon Charlie's
journey is documented by Eggers in the
monk of mocha the port city mocha on the
Red Sea is where the first ever coffee
beans were exported in the 15th century
the amount of pluck and just moukhtar
calls it naive arrogance that goes into
sort of starting a business from scratch
going to Yemen not knowing anything
about coffee cultivation and creating a
business and rallying and organizing all
these farmers around a new idea of a new
way of life it was just incredibly
inspiring naive arrogance yeah I think
the lack of knowledge really helped me
because the in the early days that had
these SWAT diagrams that I would write
up strengths weaknesses opportunities
and threats
so under threats I had things like Al
Qaeda pirates political stability you
know things that any lot of minor yeah
but they standard for any startup you
know Algerian pirates and and you know
looking back at these reports I wrote
myself I'm like boy was I thinking on
the pro side it was this might work the
pro side he was building a bridge
between two worlds Eggers is known for
telling personal stories including his
own his first book a heartbreaking work
of staggering genius was a memoir about
raising his younger brother after losing
both parents to cancer it went to number
one on the New York Times bestseller
list for this book Eggers spent years
listening to Alcon Shelley's story
travelling with him from California to
Africa your story is the most personal
asset that you have and I couldn't have
done it with anyone else to be able to
be that vulnerable Davison was very
caring and very loving and and that made
it much easier to do because some of the
parts of the book are really hilarious
but others we had a lot of tissue paper
during one trip to Yemen Alcon Shelley
found himself trapped as bombs from the
Houthi rebels rained down on the capital
Yemen's Civil War had begun in these
blasts these air strikes there's no
pattern they're just very super attic
and you heard the ground shake and
children crying and it was very hard to
live that moment the people were really
weeping and at one point people stopped
weeping and there was a sort of kind of
tranquility that came about you know we
just we decided just to submit and let
go and know that we're not in control
anymore and that feeling really helped
me a lot and so what was that process
like talking to him and taking him
through your story well in particular
because they've had an idea for side
have started backwards a lot of those
traumatic experiences that just happened
to me just a few weeks before so going
really deep into the pain you know and
to those moments with Dave in a way was
somewhat therapeutic for me it's a good
idea
tough idea but a good idea well we
I always go into it knowing at any point
we can stop and nothing gets printed
without moktari's approval and we meet
when he wants to meet and we talk about
whatever he's comfortable talking about
that's why it takes a long time almost
three years in this case what surprised
you most about the process with him I
guess I came in to coffee as a skeptic
I'd had my first cup of coffee and I was
35 when my daughter was born and I
needed some mental acuity during the day
I needed a different kind of caffeine
and I used it just as fuel I've put a
lot of sugar and just drank it to stay
awake I was still kind of cynical about
the $4 and 75 cent cup of coffee or more
expensive I thought that's ridiculous
that's so pretentious and but then to
sort of backtrack and think like well
what should something cost and and and
the coffee gets picked individually
every cherry has to be chosen by a
picker put in the put in their bag I'm
always thinking of the person who first
picks that back ripe ruby red cherry you
can't get these people out of your mind
the monk of MOCA gradually weaves
together the history of coffee Alcon
shali and his ancestral home three years
later the war there continues it's
perfect situation the single worst
humanitarian crisis in the world 18
million people are food insecure that's
70 percent of the population there's
over 3 million refugees now because of
this war
and for me on one hand I do get and I
feel that I'm helping my farmers make
him make it better living and helping
people learn more about Yemen but I
sometimes do feel that it's a small debt
compared to suffering that's going on
and I know this war will end and I
believe that my project would outlast
these bombs he thinks coffee can heal
division here at home as well there's a
cup of coffee it's crossed cultures and
borders and political hardships find its
way to you and I think it's an
incredible opportunity for us to really
be engage each other for CBS this
morning Saturday Jeff Glor New York I
love what Dave Eggers said at the
beginning of Jeff's story nobody dreams
the American Dream better than
immigrants and kudos to him for drawing
global attention and domestic attention
to the absolute crisis unfolding in
Yemen that is a beautiful story it is